with china's endorsement it was just a
question of how big john lee's winning
margin would be
to give the appearance of an open
contest the secret votes were presented
to the election committee before being
counted congratulations a landslide
1416 votes
in his acceptance speech lee promised to
lead a hong kong that was caring open
vibrant and vigilant
safeguarding our country's sovereignty
national security and development
interests
protecting hong kong from
internal and external threats and
ensuring its stability will continue to
be of parliament importance
the former number two in the hong kong
government had previously served as
security chief authorizing the use of
tear gas rubber bullets and occasional
live rounds to disperse protesters
during the unrest of 2019
it was an election day of one candidate
three protesters
and lots of police
seven thousand officers in fact enough
to keep the few dissenting voices well
away from the convention center where
the vote was held
analysts say that john lee has china's
trust but winning the trust of hong kong
could be more difficult trust can be
rebuilt through several ways one way is
by restoring accountable government in
hong kong which has been debased i would
say under the
administration of carrie lamb
so that requires the cooperation of the
media of legco
of civil society
sunday was also mother's day in hong
kong some people we spoke to were aware
there was an election but just weren't
sure of the candidate's name do you know
who won
john
oh i forgot his surname but yeah john so
you are aware of the chief executive
relationship yeah but do you know who
won the election sir there's only one
candidates
who else
hong kong people were supposed to choose
their leader for the first time in 2017.
it didn't happen then it hasn't happened
now raising the prospect that this could
be the model for future elections to
choose hong kong's leader
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong